[Music]
Jona you say that
Channing likes to torture you between
takes I've read that but I don't know
what you mean by the torture physical
taking physical torture what is it he
does to you what does he do what is that
you're witnessing it and it sucks it
just is like first there's I guess
there's some area like above your knee
yes god damn it I'm all flustered now I
there's like an area above your knee
like before your thighs starts that just
feels like a billion knives are crashing
into you at the same time and whenever
he's bored he just squeezes this yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
nothing it's actually a fake leg you
have yeah you like legs like mahogany he
didn't get through to you when I was a
kid after I had a friend whose dad used
to do that and it was everyone hated the
country things are good
is there a way to get him to stop doing
that
oh no he's like way bigger and stronger
than I am it's just like I beg him you
know I've literally cried from this
happening at times because you really do
hate it you don't like it it's not a fun
bit for you
[Applause]
[Laughter]